tu as la vocation qui peut devenir une
vraie guerrière mais pour y parvenir
souviens toi que toi et on sabre vous
devenez fait rien
ça caille
rats ils ont apporté quelque chose qui
va peut être vous aider à vous rappeler
ce qui vous est arrivé
qu'est ce que vous voulez ce sabre
parlez moi de lui il est très ancien et
très rare il ya des mecs qui payerait
d'après fortune pour la voir je suis
certain qu'ils sont liés aux yakuzas
le katana tu as retrouvé toi et lui vous
ne faites plus qu'un va c'est ta vie qui
est en jeu
j'ai une question à poser
[Musique]
ce n'est pas le katana qui intéresse
c'est top c'est autre chose c'est à moi
qui l'ont vu pourquoi il me poursuivre
toute ta famille a été massacrée
personne ne peut enterrer son passé je
ne veux pas être piégés par an passé qu
il m'appartiendra du vélomoteur loi no 4
en avoir marre
honneur et mon nom notre guerre nous
attend
la guerre est le seul chemin
c'est ton destin
non non m